hey guys today it is the sixth of April
my name is just and here's a bunch of
news primarily concerning gaming
Bethesda has announced that the open
beta for doom will begin on April 15 and
end on April eighteenth the pc ps4 and
xbox one beta will show off the games
team deathmatch and warpath modes on the
heat wave and infernal maps over which
were in the closed beta the thurs to
have said these maps and modes are just
a fraction of what players will
experience when the game launches Mather
team adding support for doom doesn't end
when the game's out for the rest of the
year we expect to provide certain free
content updates across snap map and
multiplayer Jim is also set to feature
three paid multiplayer DLC packs which
will cost 15 bucks apiece although there
is also a season pass option which will
cost you forty dollars the first pack
will include three new maps a new weapon
a new playable demon a new armor set one
new piece of gear as well as new hack
modules taunts and customization options
Gears of War for developer the Coalition
has revealed that the game is going to
launch on october eleventh the Devourer
have said harkening back to the dark and
intense roots of the original classic
fans can expect a familiar yet distinct
evolution of gameplay including brutal
and interaction a heart-pounding
campaign genre-defining multiplayer and
stunning visuals powered by Unreal
Engine 4 keys voss multiplayer beta is
set to begin on April 18 although to get
in you'll need to have played gears of
war Ultimate Edition by April 11 we also
got our first look at the box art for
the newest game in the franchise and the
surprise it's a dude holding a gun I
don't know what I was expecting finally
Square Enix has confirmed that the Final
Fantasy 7 remake will be comprised of
multiple full-sized games and not short
episode producing yoshinori kitase I
told Game Informer it will essentially
be a full-scale game for each part of
the multi-part series in final fantasy
13 each installment told the story from
a different angle it was kind of like
approaching an unknown
ritory innocence whereas with Final
Fantasy 7 remake we already have a
pre-existing story so it wouldn't really
make sense if that isn't encompassed in
a multi-part series so we're just
looking at each of these parts one part
should be on par with the scale of one
final fantasy 13 game he added that
while they don't intend to change
everything Square Enix are taking some
liberties with the existing story to
modernize it let me know down in the
comments what you think about the
fallout of the Final Fantasy 7 remake
and head to gamespot we've got news on
overwatch and a PSN sale that's
everything I have you today but do let
you know what mattered to you and I will
see you again to work